[Musique]
de retrouver votre invité Frédéric
rivière vous recevez ce matin Bruno
Millien député et porte-parole du MoDem
et du groupe démocrate à l'Assemblée
nationale bonjour à vous melisabeth
borne indiqué hier que le gouvernement
ferait connaître son choix sur la
méthode retenue pour faire passer la
réforme des retraites à la fin de la
semaine ça fait d'ailleurs me
semble-t-il plusieurs fois qu'il est
question que ce soit dans quelques jours
la chef du gouvernants a précisé que
pour l'instant toutes les options
étaient sur la table les universités
d'été du MoDem ce week-end ont été
l'occasion pour un certain nombre de
cadres de votre mouvement de réaffirmer
leur opposition un passage en force
est-ce que vous avez des raisons de
penser que le Président de la République
va entendre votre mise en garde je sais
pas si j'ai des raisons de penser qu'il
va le faire mais la raison voudrait
qu'il le fasse pour une raison simple en
2017 on est élu avec le président Macron
sur une réforme des retraites mais une
réforme des retraites systémique avec
plus de justice sociale avec la retraite
par point qui permet qu'à chaque cotiser
chaque heure travaillé donne droit à
cotisations aujourd'hui on le sait notre
régime de retraite qui nous a aidé dans
la protection sociale de beaucoup de
gens est un peu à bout de souffle en
tout cas il est injuste pour les femmes
pour les carrières hachées pour les
carrières longues pour la pénibilité
pour le travail des seniors il faut
qu'on travaille dessus aussi enfin il y
a plein de cases qui ne vont pas si on
doit faire une réforme des retraites
elle doit être systémique elle doit pas
être juste paramétrique et aujourd'hui
il semble qu'il ne soit plus question
d'une retraite par point on entend le
président n'a parlé pendant sa campagne
mais certes une fois mais il en a parlé
j'aimerais bien qu'il serait exprime
là-dessus parce que vous pouvez regarder
tous les régimes de retraite qui
existent alors il y a des erreurs dans
le texte qui a été votée au 49-3 en 2020
on a peut-être été trop loin dans
l'histoire de l'universalité en voulant
réunir tous les régimes en un seul
peut-être qu'on aurait dû le faire par
étape je pense notamment au régime des
avocats qui est qui est autosuffisant et
qui avait peut-être pas besoin de ça
mais voilà il y avait peut-être par
étape il y a eu aussi cette histoire
d'âge pivot vous voyez bien que l'âge
pivot cristallise les refus parce que je
pense pas donc là l'âge pivot ça veut
rien dire moi je suis né en 59 ma
retraite à taux plein et pourtant j'ai
pas trop dans ma carrière je la prendrai
à 67 ans si on compte la retraite de la
sécurité sociale et celle agir Carco la
retraite complémentaire donc ça veut
rien dire là je pivot où là je de départ
et aujourd'hui le conseil dans
l'orientation des retraites dit que il
va y avoir des déficits dans les
prochaines années que pour autant ces
déficits ne sont pas forcément
dramatiques puisqu'il est question de
déficit de résiduel pourquoi selon vous
le président de la République veut-il
absolument faire une réforme des
retraites rapidement alors d'abord parce
qu'une réforme des retraites c'est
compliqué à mettre en place
effectivement il faut la faire
rapidement il veut la faire avant la fin
de son dernier quinquennat il parle de
ce qu'elle soit en oeuvre avant l'été
prochain oui parce qu'on a un problème
de déficit à partir de 2023 il me semble
ou 2022 2023 ça peut prêt ça va mais
après on rentre dans le déficit donc
tant qu'à l'affaire autant la faire tout
de suite pour avoir des applications
rapides mais ça n'empêche pas de faire
les choses dans le bon sens enfin si on
fait ça sans tenir compte des citoyens
sans tenir compte des des syndicats
enfin on va voir un problème on peut pas
être réélu sur une sur une promesse de
changement de méthode et passer en force
sur moi je le dis j'ai pas peur de le
dire même si je fais partie de la
majorité sur un amendement qui est un
amendement purement budgétaire
paramétrique pour pouvoir dégager de
l'argent tout de suite pour pouvoir
aider au financement de certains
certaines augmentations de certains
ministères comme l'éducation nationale
enfin pour moi c'est pas une réforme des
retraites à ce moment-là qu'on dise la
vérité aux gens on dit voilà on vous
avez travaillé plus longtemps pour qu'on
donne plus d'argent aux autres mais
c'est pas est-ce que dans l'hypothèse
d'un passage en force c'est à dire donc
d'un amendement dans le cadre du projet
de loi de la sécurité sociale est-ce que
ça serait une façon en quelque sorte de
de tuer dans l'oeuf le Conseil national
de la refondation ah ben le Conseil
national de la refondation aura du plan
dans l'aile parce que d'abord vous
pouvez être sûr que les syndicats qui
sont venus et je rappelle quand même à
vos audits d'ailleurs je rappelle quand
même à vos auditeurs que cette première
journée de réunion à huis clos du
Conseil national de la Fondation a été
un succès enfin les gens s'attendaient
pas à pouvoir discuter aussi ouvertement
à pouvoir mettre les choses sur la table
à pouvoir prévoir une espèce de
calendrier des sujets qui pourraient qui
pourraient que pour évoquer le CNR donc
ils ont sorti tout se content si on fait
ça c'est d'abord la preuve que le
changement de méthode n'est pas là et
donc le CNR oui François Bayrou l'a dit
d'ailleurs et je suis d'accord avec lui
le CNR aurait du plomb dans la rue que
font les élus MoDem si toutefois le
gouvernement décidait de passer en force
s'il dépose l'amendement on l'a dit on
la redit c'est pas une menace c'est une
profonde conviction c'est pas nous on
est pour la réforme des retraites telle
qu'elle avait été définie en 2020 en
2000 oui en 2020 on est absolument
contre un passage en force d'un
amendement il y aurait une unité de
votre mouvement et dans votre rencontre
l'amendement oui le projet de budget
2023 a été présenté hier en
les inquiétudes à ce sujet et que vous
travaillez à établir des propositions
pour rendre le dispositifs plus juste et
plus acceptable c'est-à-dire au fond
pour l'assouplir dans quelle direction
travailler on est on est avec mon
collègue Gérard le sol qui est
socialiste on est co-rapporteur d'une
mission flash justement sur les aides
c'est le moment de faire le point parce
qu'on sentait bien qu'il y avait
énormément d'irritant et il fallait
qu'on mette les choses sur la table et
qu'on voit exactement où on en est
aujourd'hui comment se développent les
aid des feux dans les différentes
métropoles qui s'en sont emparés d'abord
on s'aperçoit que ça se développe à des
vitesses différentes avec des
critérisation différentes et que
peut-être il est temps de remettre un
petit peu d'ordre dans tout ça en accord
avec les associations d'élus mais aussi
en accord avec les associations de
consommateurs pour qu'on voit comment on
peut essayer de faire en sorte que cette
grande cause de santé environnementale
qui est la lutte contre la pollution de
l'air puisse être acceptable par tous le
problème c'est pas tant les gens qui
sont à l'intérieur des adefe parce que
si vous prenez les grandes métropoles
vous habitez Paris alors ça peut être
effectivement gênant
de temps en temps mais vous avez tous
les moyens de mobilité pour ne pas
utiliser votre voiture le problème c'est
oui on cite souvent par exemple le cas
aussi de l'artisan qui habite à 30 km de
Paris qui doit venir travailler dans le
centre de Paris
dans le métro c'est pas pratique non
mais il y a plein de questions est-ce
que par exemple pour livrer le dernier
kilomètre il vaut mieux x 3 tonnes 5 qui
roulent à l'électrique ou au gaz ou un
26 tonnes qui roule au gaz enfin il y a
plein de questions tout ça tous ces
sujets là on les a levés et vous aurez
notre rapport le 12 octobre sur la table
et vous pensez que le gouvernement aussi
est ouvert sur ce sujet est prêt bah là
c'est éventuellement des
assouplissements pour rendre les choses
plus acceptables nous ce qu'on a fixé
dans la loi on n'a pas fait on a fixé un
calendrier d'arrivée on n'a pas fixé le
calendrier de comment arriver à ce
calendrier à l'arrivée donc ça on a
laissé la main au collectivité
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que les
collectivités
d'après nos auditions ont effectivement
besoin de faire un point peut-être pour
certaines harmonisations qui pourraient
être nationales je vous donne juste un
exemple rapidement si vous prenez trois
métropoles comme Lyon Grenoble et demain
Saint-Étienne puis après Annecy si c'est
comme si ces métropoles là n'ont pas une
certaine harmonisation c'est un
casse-tête invraisemblable pour les
artisans commerçants mais même pour les
particuliers de savoir s'ils ont le
droit ou pas de rentrer dans les
différentes ZF il ne resterait peu de
temps mais peut-être un mot sur on a vu
ce week-end enfin ce dimanche la
victoire de Fratelli d'Italia de George
et Mélanie en Italie en France 89
députés du rassemblement national en
Suède un parti les Démocrates suédois
qui est très en tête qui est un parti
est qualifier d'extrême droite c'est
pour vous c'est une lame de fond c'est
un phénomène structurel ou conjoncturel
non je pense que c'est une lame de fond
parce que les démocrates de tous les
pays malheureusement aujourd'hui on
n'arrive pas à mettre sur la table des
solutions simples visibles et
appréhendables par les citoyens
fois qu'on arrivera à pas à mettre des
solutions claires sur la table qui
peuvent voir ils essaieront toujours le
mouvement qu'ils n'ont pas encore essayé
c'est ce qui s'est passé en Italie et
c'est grave et c'est très grave merci
pour nos millièmes bonne journée à vous